I'm having issues playing the game
quote/unquote at work I'm quiet and
friendly but I prefer to work hard
rather rather than stand out and talk I
found I have trouble forming more
personal connections with my boss and
coworkers
what are your tips so look when I talk
about playing the game I'm not talking
about the fact that you have to change
your entire personality profile to start
to connect with people that's not what
I'm saying don't have to go from being
someone that's what they say quiet and
friendly
you don't have to become some chatty
extrovert running around making small
talk with anybody and on top of that
there's a little bit of a statement here
that says you know I'd rather work hard
as if there's these are mutually
exclusive things which they are
certainly not so this being forming
relationships with people and playing
the game does not interfere with your
work at all I'm not saying that you sit
around and talk when there's work to be
done but there's gonna be natural breaks
in whatever you're doing there's gonna
be moments where skip the action pauses
and you get a chance to connect with
somebody so that's fine so so what are
some tips that how would you do this so
I thought about this of you wanna start
with something small right but you want
to engage this is the key point I don't
just want to throw something at you I
want to talk at you and besides when
it's much easier just to let someone
talk about themselves so the one I'm
what my advice in this particular
question is is to tell them something
about yourself like something minor
about yourself but then that kind of
ties into something that you can ask
them mm-hmm and then they can talk to
you because most people like to talk
about themselves so you ask them a
question about themselves and then you
go so you know something something maybe
something slightly related to work so
it's not just some random statement that
you're making you know you'd say
you know what we did it yesterday at
work you're reminded me of something
right reminded me of something else and
then maybe it reminded me of a movie ma
you know what we were doing yesterday
reminded me of this movie every scene
that movie mm-hmm and at least you're
gonna get well no cuz I don't watch a
lot of movies or no I haven't seen that
movie or oh I've seen that we leave it's
a popular movie but chances are they're
seeing it you know what I mean and all
of a sudden you've got a little bit of a
conversation going and that's all we're
looking for we're not looking to turn
into like chatty catty
mm-hm we're just trying to build build
relationships with people so you know
who they are so that they know who you
are that's what we're talking about
nothing crazy
start small build from there mm-hmm yeah
pretty straightforward yeah in and
through that building process what I
kind of found is one and I guess maybe
this is a little tactical thing you can
kind of throw out whenever but you know
and you know when people give you advice
or they tell you something about
themselves that's something I don't know
whatever whatever the story is right and
maybe some strategy they used to do X Y
Z it can be super small if you let them
know that you remembered like in the
future later on when you zoom again you
say I remembered what you said last week
you know tie-in this yeah and just say
oh it can be the smallest a purple belt
jujitsu mental jujitsu I like it it give
me the smallest thing and it just makes
you feel good so that of that person
will just essentially feel more open
with you they're like oh my gosh this
guy really pays attention to me oh yeah
makes him feel valuable all that stuff
just on that small level you know so as
far as building little patience
I'd say that's a cool thing to kind of
remember to do if you can't
that's it that's a cool kind of thing to
remember too